ich bin ich hier ich bin nicht neu habt
ihr das gesehen hat sie es gerade
gesehen
davide jona was geht hier ist euer max
und wir spielen heute ein ründchen gta 5
wir werden einfach ein bisschen trouble
bisschen ärger machen ich habe mich
relativ gut ausgestattet also dass
einfach der spielstand wo ich das spiel
schon durch haben ist erst mal irgend
gutes auto und dann werden wir probieren
also erstmal natürlich das auto richtig
schön ausstatten
nehmen wir den teuersten ja von den
neuen modellen erstmal wären wir das
ding schön ausstatten
und dann werden wir probieren fünf
sterne zu kriegen und dann werden wir
probieren 5 sterne los zu werden indem
wir abbauen vor den polizisten jetzt
erstmal auto ab und fahren ach so eine
sache die ihr wahrscheinlich gar nicht
wisst ich chatte bei gta immer also ich
mache meistens aber immer nur diese herz
schied dass ich nicht sterben aber
irgendwie gehört aber irgendwie gehört
schicken und gta zusammenfinden so
natürlich sagen wir machen einfach ein
kleines ritual wenn wir irgend etwas
tolles neues kriegen werden wir das alte
dame in die luft jagen so dass alte
autos weg und jetzt können wir uns das
neue holen und das tun aber dafür muss
ich erst mal wieder die kopflos werden
falls ihr reparieren fans von beste
panzerung fremden brennenden stoßstange
die sieht gut aus
ist gut aus sekundär farbe immer ich in
dem immer matte farben oder sieht das
sieht schon gut aus das teil so dass ein
minister sieht auch gut aus
betriebe natürlich das beste turbo
natürlich rein felgen für tuner felgen
diese nicht gut aus sportfelgen ja dann
nehmen wir diesen teil aus fälligen
farbe gold rest müsste heft die aus den
seitenteilen gibt es gold ja ja das
sieht gut aus und fenster genau sie ne
also im auto perfekt das teil sieht
verdammt scharf aus gras und kurzzeitig
an und mainz werk passt perfekt dazu
ja und ich sagen einfach los wir haben
keine zeit zu verlieren und produzieren
wir die cops ein bisschen älter das
zeigt wie das los ok kann mir auch erst
mal eine veränderte
so gewiss wie flipper der cd ab ich cd
ab ich sehr schön finde das ist ein
guter start dieser bus so mein freund
vor davor und seht ihr schon möglich die
die jetzt hier noch um holen damit ich
direkt bei zwei stellen und mein auto
sieht aber nicht mehr so schön aus mit
dem auto kann nicht alles schaffen
ich kann alles schaffen mit dem auto zum
übrigens leid dass dieses video unnötige
gewalt enthält aber das ist einfach geht
wer was anderes sagt
hallo freunde und bleibt von wenigstens
drei sterne haben wir schon mal dass ich
schieße habe ich bereits gesagt glaube
ich manchmal stelle trotzdem seit fünf
stellen macht sie mir aus ob man
schüttet oder nicht weil dann sind die
cops so gut dass sie einfach kein krieg
mehr darauf geben ob man also das ist
einfach kein unterschied mehr macht so
kommt ihr erstmal alle her nähert euch
ruhig an
so fertig jetzt annäherungs minen sehr
schön
es war cool einfach durch diese wende
durch posen
der ist auch schon tot wie sie heute
dahin alter warten kann man eigentlich
nichts gebrauchen aber für so was
natürlich hat er store genannt es war
der erste helikopter deswegen ein
bisschen abstand gewinnen und dann wird
der typ sich vorgeknöpft ausländer
helikopters mit dem auto zu fahren
richtig geil so als ob alter leute die
gut für uns geschaffen diese rampe ich
habe ihn noch nicht gemacht ich hab voll
wenigen von diesem super stunts ich hab
mir nicht irgendwelches spieletipps oder
sowas angeschaut um das alles durch zu
suchen sondern ich habe einfach nur die
story des auftritten das war es
eigentlich schon
aha com wir schaffen den sprung
eigentlich müssen wir wollen wir noch ja
wir legen noch eine haftbombe hin
so dass wir dann gleich rüber springen
können denn wir irgendwann schaffen
sollten
ja ich bin spielen aber gta ist einfach
ein tolles spiel
und
auch ich konnte sie nicht explodieren
lassen verdammt aber als ob freunde das
muss nicht sein
soweit ich kann vielleicht noch ein
bisschen senken wer vorne führt dieses
teil umgehauen haben wir echt unnötig
nein ich will nicht rein
diese helikopter ging mir hart auf die
nerven
so steht man kein gta so was soll man es
jetzt schön auto bei versucht nummer
zwei hinter nike ist wichtig für freunde
wie immer altes auto muss weg neues auto
kommt her
ich hab mir jetzt diesen coolen
geländewagen geholt wie sieht er aus ich
sage dann gleich so freunde autos fertig
so schauts aus wieder sehr schön
geworden finde ich und es passt
natürlich wie immer zum swatch und jetzt
kommen wir noch mal die polizisten vor
ich werde keine waffen nachkaufen so
leid es tut mir sehr leid freunde der
sonne aber mit diesem auto können wir
erfolg haben es probiert ihre endlich
jahr sehr schöne freundin wir fahren
jetzt auf dem berghof perfekt dass wir
dieses gelände auto haben nummer 1 und
nummer 2
noch keine sechs sterne das schaffen wir
noch freuen darf nicht aufgeben
vermutlich dass er allein hoch so die da
unten schnappen wir uns so zum glück
sind wir weg sind wir schusssicher hat
dessen sehen freunde deshalb gut ich
glaube es war viel los
ja es war viel los auf der peter ist
einfach abgedreht voll abgedreht oder
freunde ganz sterne
ich kann abbauen ok so dumm aber ich
glaube das schlauste es echt wenn auf
den bergen willen einfach über die berge
abzuhauen wenn vielleicht die helis noch
mal runter zu schießen schafft er das
blei bis zum noch ein bisschen höher
kommt nein meine tür
ich brauche meine tür ob so wie ich ich
hole mir die gleich die beiden fahren
auch mal schön auf dem berg so dass sie
gar nicht machen können so der weg und
du bist auch gleich werk und da kommt
schon am nächsten tag weiter die kommen
jetzt schneller als es geht
die story an diejenigen die sich der rat
ab sein wollten
bitte nicht auf mein auto bau so jetzt
bin ich schon mal außer sichtweite
und es muss sie aber probieren auf den
bergen zu bleiben ohne dass die menschen
kommen yahoo
gott sei dank habe ich schon wieder ihr
blöden ratten
wir fliegen jetzt einfach über die berge
wow ist es so schwierig man muss wenn
man nebenbei nachkommt wir können ein
bisschen variieren bisschen was was
selbst machen treffen wahrscheinlich
seht ihr mich doch treffen kommt jedoch
geht noch weiter peter peter unterkofler
als auf der das aushält
so jetzt aber und da ist der nächste
freunde ist reicht ich war jetzt einfach
über die berge vielleicht kann ich doch
nur schnell genug sein
wo landet
doch ein baum ist charakter tut ihr das
lernen
lasst mich doch einfach green so ist er
weg jetzt sind schon diese ganzen boden
menschen da kurz außer sichtweite kommt
bleibt da nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein ich
bin ich hier ich bin nicht neu habt ihr
das gesehen habe gerade gesehen
lustig war das denn er läuft führt
direkt neben mir und mini an ich war der
typ den du gesucht hast okay hier runter
okay wir machen es nach dem sprung im
merziger ohr alter walter alter okay
aber alles gut
oh nein nein nein
daraus sei überfällig damit packe
so mein freund du bist jetzt erstmal vom
himmel geholt dessen zustand ernst
dieses dumme freude das ist jetzt nicht
sein ernst
komm schon du bist mein auto mit einem
gezielten wurf müssen wir probieren das
freizusprengen ja das war der plan
freunde ich habe ein problem ich war
entschied so freunde
wir haben ein auto wieder zum glück ist
da und es ist einfach ins sind kaputt es
ist einfach unfreundlich gott glaube man
wird einfach die fünf ländern nicht los
langsam will ich es endlich schaffen
hier unten sind eigentlich auch immer
recht
so lasst mich hier mal in ruhe bitte
nicht alle vorbei man sieht mich hier
nicht das geht gar nicht ich bin
unsichtbar jetzt gleich weiter
ausgestiegen sind hin und her oder tut
mir leid polizisten
eagle one ich hasse diese scheiß teile
diese dummen he lies mal wenn jetzt
gleichsam auf gang kommen würde hätte
das war nicht meine absicht mehr
bitte bitte bitte bitte
ich habe irgendwo einen coolen secret
weg gefunden wenn ich mit dem weg die
nicht abhängen kann dann kann ich gar
nicht einfach stehen bleiben einfach
stehen beim einfach stehen bleiben
alte freunde ist könnte es könnte der
weg sein
im stern loszuwerden komm komm komm komm
schon kamera
ja freunde
wir haben's geschafft
wir sind 5 sterne los geworden alter
schwede ich habe 40 minuten lang
aufgenommen
wirklich geschafft was für ein
wunderschönes porträt panorama ja ich
hoffe euch jetzt auch gefallen ich
fand's lustig manche werden sagen das
war unnötig
alles ist unnötig